there's a parent right now
a number of parents in the north penn
school district right outside of philly
who showed up to a school board meeting
to report on something that if this
mother had not had courage we probably
never would have heard of this came from
libs of tick tock that a fifth grade
teacher
lined up students by their race these
are ten-year-olds and made the white
kids apologize to the black kids
i actually pulled my daughter out of am
cult
because of the fifth grade teacher who
lined those students up from whitest to
darkest made them turn around and the
white ones need to apologize to the
black ones now do not tell me that it
did not happen
okay in this district you need to put an
end to this
kids do not see color and you are
segregating them and you are separating
them
this is not okay
do something or get out of those damn
chairs
i love it i love her righteous anger and
i love the point that she's making this
is not okay the teachers who do this
need to be canceled they need to be
fired they need to not work as teachers
again i love cancel culture canceled
culture is awesome when it's for the
right reasons all cultures cancel every
single person supports cancel culture
plenty of people who pretend to hate
cancer culture right now are calling to
they're calling to cancel whoopi
goldberg maybe they have good reason to
i think there are plenty of good reasons
to ostracize people there are standards
there are taboos there are consequences
for what people say of course
certainly that should be enforced
against this teacher
without question now
it actually ties in with the whoopi
point a little bit too because let's
take away all of whoopi's stupid
historical commentary on the holocaust
and let's just get to the
ostensibly deeper philosophical point
she's trying to make which is that
evil doesn't just boil down to race it
boils down to man's inhumanity toward
man it really boils down to the
perversion and fallenness of man's heart
if it is the case
that it's really all about race all evil
in the world is about race and white
supremacy then the exercise that this
teacher is doing in her classroom is
totally justified
if it's really if the all the problems
of the world stem from white supremacy
then yeah the white kids probably should
apologize to the black kids shouldn't
they and they should be taught that
whiteness is bad and blackness is good
and white people should always feel
ashamed of their skin color
and you've got a root out out damn spot
out damn whiteness right if if
the racial ideology of the left is true
if it's not if racism is merely a
symptom of a deeper fallenness of the
world
that is not merely about one group or
some other group but is actually about
the man in the mirror and our own
cracked broken
hearts that are corrupt from the
beginning
well then this exercise doesn't make any
sense at all
and
the answer to this by the way
is not the what the libs are doing right
now is they're saying one group good the
other group evil
what a lot of people want all the kids
to be told is you're all good you're all
good people deep down what the kids
should really be taught is no you're all
fallen you're not totally evil
you're not 100 irredeemable
but you're not good either you're fallen
and you need humility and you are a
sinner that's the nature of this world
and we need to practice virtue and we
need to be on guard against sin and we
need a redeemer
that is what i know it sounds so radical
now to say that that's what education
was until like five minutes ago
by which i mean 60 70 years ago when the
secularists really took over the
educational institution and what
happened since that time our education
has crumbled and little 10 year olds are
being told to feel ashamed of themselves
for the color of their skin
this is a lot deeper than just some
stupid racial theory this is this
requires an entire overhaul of how we
see ourselves and our country with the
historic inflation that we're all
dealing with today it's more important
than ever to save some money you ever
wonder how to strike the best deals and
save up to i don't know ninety percent
nine zero on brand new items without
even needing to leave your home look no
further than deal dash one of the
leading auction sites in the united
states with over a decade in business
whether you are in the market for a
basic kitchen appliance or a luxury
upgrade to your old tv deal dash will
allow you to get the best deals on
whatever you're looking for they've got
hundreds of auctions daily on brand new
items from tvs and laptops to tools and
kitchenware even cars with guaranteed
free shipping ipads have sold for 33.60
brand new cars have sold for less than
one thousand dollars all auctions start
at zero dollars you have a 90 day money
back guarantee on your first bid pack
purchase you can use deal dash both
online at deal dash dot com as well as
through ios and android apps the game
mechanics are simple all auctions start
at zero bucks each bid raises the final
auction price by one cent and resets the
clock to 10 seconds after the 10 seconds
run out the final bitter wins and can
claim the auction win by paying the
final price don't be made victim to
today's inflation get all the new
products that you desire without price
hikes at deal dash today use promo code
knowles canon wles for an additional 100
free bids when making your first bid
pack purchase and start bidding hey oh
thanks for checking out that clip that's
cool man nice to be with you if you want
more clips
ring the bell subscribe leave a five
star review on apple podcast spot if i
stitch your google play wherever you get
your audio podcasts get it here at
youtube get it at the daily wire get it
on your audio podcast app get it
anywhere you can
to stave off the sensors we'll see you
next time
[Music]
[Music]
you